c'est vraiment dégueulasse
jean louis est un havre de paix loin en
vingt ans vingt ans de bois le via les
leurs en place par à mes questions et
les mecs qui bossent pour rien ils font
des heures sup api
ils vont même pas l'église le dimanche
les gars c'est vraiment une bonne
attention moi j'ai rien contre les
pokémon à condition qu'ils restent chez
eux parce que quand ils viennent en
france pour piquer des allocations
familiales pica pica pica allocations
familiales même pas foutu de parler
français
pica pica pica pica pica tokyo moi je ne
veux pas de pokémon chez moi ils
répètent en boucle on n'est pas des
voleurs on n'est pas des voleurs
n'empêche que quand il ya des voitures
qui sont brûlés c'est les pokémon
ce qui vu avec des pokémon toute façon
ce par intérêt
oui j'ai quelques amis dresseur de
pokémon vous dirige bien très bien
ay roop ans quand vous les gars quoi eh
ben c'est la structure en quatre aides
en chemin encore un message veut pas le
savoir tu sais qu'un match ce soir c'est
aussi que t'as pas de paquet donc je
continue comme ça on va là mais c'est
quoi ces charters pour bhopal est
indirecte a vite repris la foule
électricité
[ __ ] [ __ ] de toi que tu as chaud
picard mais bien sûr qu'on a besoin des
pokémon dans les années 90 ok mais là
c'est bon ils peuvent rentrer chez eux
on sent pas en sécurité avec eux
toujours à se battre j'ai tout c'est bon
là moi j'ai peur bon bah comme la
semaine dernière cette fois que je gagne
parce que j'ai perdu tous mes pages
accuse étoiles est à l'or olympique à
pic à trois méga voilà ça c'est beau
champion
à
cinq mois de procès battra pas des
tonnes le lavage à m'échauffer à la clé
il a peut être pas bien et je le connais
pas du tout partagé par mois
attrapez le temps que tu as peut-être
que tu as chaud et un peu de ta [ __ ]
chou pk